yeah so i'm going to jump right into it
what's your opinion of simps
wait ah i thought we were going to ask
do you do uh v chewers poop is that a
real
oh yeah yeah yeah so do people do
do do tootie anime girls poop that's a
wonderful question the truth is i don't
actually know oh
didn't expect that all right all right
i'm sorry back to you
hold on you don't know dang i don't know
about and about anime girls or youtubers
but i am death and death does not have
to so
i can't actually answer yeah i was gonna
say like do you not know as in like
you don't or you don't know as in like
it just comes out without you
like you're not even aware that it's out
i
don't think it's that one but back to
your question
what's your opinion on sims what's a
youtuber's opinion on sims you mean
shrimps
shrimps oh yes i think that's that's
what gouda calls them
yes oh yes um i think that's that is the
term that humans today are using for
uh supporters avid supporters i don't
really
um all i know is that uh sometimes in in
chat when i'm streaming
uh they throw rainbows at me and i tell
them to stop but then they keep doing it
and the more that i tell them to stop uh
the more that they uh continue to do it
and i don't i still don't really know
how to handle it to be honest um
but i think i think everyone is very is
very well meaning and i'm happy for the
support
i've seen the clip of all those like
canadians like boys
super chat sure did happen huh
and it's probably gonna happen again
let's be real i suppose you're right huh